crece la preocupación en Europa después
de las informaciones de un reportaje de
investigación publicado por varios
medios de comunicación de países
nórdicos en que alertan que supuestos
barcos de pesca supuestos barcos de
científicos son en realidad barcos de
espías rusos que lo que tratan es de
sabotear todos los cables submarinos que
hay en todas esta zona pero también los
parques eólicos además lo que tratan es
también de vigilar en caso de un posible
conflicto con el oeste de hecho todos
estos parques eólicos todos estos cables
se encuentran desde Bélgica hasta toda
la zona de los países nórdicos Así que
piden que hay que estar extremadamente
vigilantes de hecho según informaciones
del gobierno de Países Bajos han
alertado de posibles actividades
inusuales en la zona y que hay que
vigilar para evitar posibles espionajes
el asunto es de extrema importancia más
aún después del Sabotaje del gasoducto
nord Stream el pasado septiembre en que
según informaciones provenientes desde
Dinamarca aseguran de que hay pruebas de
que hubo barcos rusos en la zona justo
días antes del Sabotaje del nord Stream
el próximo lunes precisamente se va a
celebrar una Cumbre entre varios países
europeos que ya estaba prevista para
hablar de cooperación en materia
energética pero que muy probablemente se
va a hablar de estas últimas
informaciones también para hablar sobre
Cómo proteger más y mejor estas
infraestructuras críticas